well hello there welcome back
first the good news our very own
benjamin hall is out of ukraine and i
hear is in good spirits after being
seriously injured we're all very
relieved to finally hear some good news
and finally ben and i have something in
common we both suffer he's in a hospital
with strangers and i have my
mother-in-law living with me
relax freaks it's a joke
now the last time i talked to him we
plan to get drunk when he's back in nyc
and i'm holding him to it mainly because
he has a british accent a perfect
hairline and a charming demeanor i'm
just going to tell everyone he's in one
direction and hope i get the leftovers
it's disgusting
so as we're on the brink of world war
what are the media geniuses obsessing
over well did you see the atlantic
magazine's take on ukraine the headline
quote on top of everything else nuclear
war would be a climate problem
yes that's the priority a country gets
vaporized but it's also one degree
warmer for the shell shock survivors and
god help them if you're a radioactive
zombie you might forget to sort your
recycling on trash day or worse the
fallout would cover the coexist sticker
on your prius
try applying that logic elsewhere sure
you might get terminal cancer but
imagine what that does to your tennis
elbow
but if only it was the media that was
this myopic the house dems want biden to
declare a national climate emergency
and why not climate emergency is the
left's second favorite freak out when
blaming everything on racism wants to
take the night off
the goal to ban oil drilling on federal
lands it's more proof the left are in
lockstep with what putin wants for us to
be dependent on other countries like his
for energy
personally i think all this green talk
is russian propaganda that's right
lefties it's you who are putin puppets
not me
speaking of putin actually claims he now
wants reparations for alaska and i say
why not how about 40 acres enjoy behar
[Laughter]
now the dems are also calling to end
fossil fuel subsidies i'm for that if by
fossil fuels they mean the five bottles
of ensure that joe drinks a day
of course how does that help the average
american well it doesn't and that's the
point it's part of the ideology of
punishment which is not just the name of
my favorite club downtown
i have my own whiplocker
but it's also how the left views policy
they don't mind high gas prices they
want them to punish us for being greedy
capitalists if i sound like aoc right
now that's the point too our energy
policies are being shaped by someone who
should be making banana daiquiris at
applebee's
this also is why they deny the crime
wave and let violent thugs off scot-free
to punish us for 400 years of oppression
apparently elderly asian women must have
owned slaves too they also lauded riots
as protest that's punishment for your
uncaring economic system let us have
free stuff or die and of course you
should wear masks indefinitely they say
because you deserve it not about safety
it's about punishment
otherwise they'd wear masks too at their
award shows and gala events but really
it's because they can't stand to see you
smile hear you speak or know that you're
breathing freely without their
permission it's the new ideology
morphing politics into morality becoming
a new religion in which there's no
forgiveness only confession followed by
penance bless me father for i have
sinned i just filled my ford f-150 with
unleaded
okay son your penance say five hail
greta's and retrofit your house with
solar panels
and since everything the left wants is
based on punishing you it's okay if it
helps our adversaries
let's take russia who duped europe into
depending on their energy by funding
rabid environmental groups as we start
to shun russian oil we're now finding
out that they actually funded green
groups that crapped on non-russian fuels
they were using disinformation within
green groups to steer countries away
from fracking and shale gas in favor of
their imported russian gas it's the
equivalent of shutting down rehab
clinics so addicts would go back to
their old ways it all makes so much
sense now doesn't it of course you need
to be a sucker to get sucked
we had leaders who took
that came out in a weird way
but we had leaders who took
environmental advice from a brat like
greta thundberg and a president who
dreamed of sniffing her hair
that's because the ideology of
punishment means punishing our industry
by bolstering theirs because we are the
oppressor so now a ditzy president
blames putin for rising prices when it
was him and his stupid party all along
fact is it takes months to affect oil
and gas prices what we're seeing now is
the direct result of joe biden's
anti-industry policies from the moment
he first soiled the oval office carpet
sadly russia and china knew what an easy
mark our virtue signaling white house
was they were happily playing chess
while our bozos got lost in the ice
cream slopes of candy land
let's be
tonight's guest he's so british
t has him for breakfast author and
political commentator
douglas murray
and he dresses for the job he wants
sailboat captain radio and podcast host
buck sexton
ceso wiry you want to hang clothes on
her foxy's contributor cat too
and he's always picked last for the
seesaw my massive sidekick in the nwa's
world television champion tyrus
so buck uh
good to see you as always thank you sir
i lie
but i am curious i am really curious
about what you think is we haven't
talked since this invasion i was curious
about what you thought of zielinski's
speech this morning i'm just curious how
you view what is going on are we being
pulled into a war should we be part of
this i feel like we are being pulled in
and now i feel like after soon that
speech you know we have to help the guy
but what do you think it does feel like
the trajectory has been moving toward
greater u.s involvement pretty quickly
it was just a few weeks ago where i
think you would have had bipartisan near
bipartisan consensus that this is not
our war we've learned after 20 years of
mideast and south asian intervention
that we want to stay out of things
especially where we don't have a clear
strategic objective now on this point
the objective would obviously be to stop
the russians but the not our war thing
still very much applies
i've heard more and more about a no-fly
zone last week than i did this week
because i think people actually figured
out what a no-fly zone would entail
right which was important and i'm glad
that that now has been established it
means you have to shoot russian planes
out of the sky russian surface-to-air
missiles including on russian soil
because the s500 can go about three or
four hundred miles i didn't really know
you'd have to do a whole lot of blowing
up things that vladimir putin would be
very upset about and he does have
thousands of nukes yeah so we're giving
a lot of weapons which i think is the
right thing we're giving humanitarian
assistance which is the right thing i
hope we hold the line on not actually
doing the fighting ourselves but i'm not
100 sure we won't we will actually i'm
i'm hoping yeah i had an idea for a a
store that only sold boxer briefs called
no-fly zone
douglas
england invaded a lot of countries admit
it
when
i don't know
what is your take on this as a brit in
america what do you how do you feel
about this i agree with buck i mean i
think that uh there's a sort of obvious
thing that there are things we can do
there's an obvious thing we've just got
to make sure we don't do yeah spark
world war three right um but but yeah i
mean it's it's it's it's a it's a tricky
time because we seem to have been
lurching from disaster to disaster in
the last few years
to such an extent that people have
forgotten i mean um you know we thank
god the one good thing that happened
when uh vladimir putin invaded ukraine
was that we got rid of tony fauci
he just he just disappeared we haven't
seen from him since um and the same
thing in the uk the government's
advisory group on covert disbanded right
so it was almost as if we could cope
with one
massive event at a time so before this
we had covet and then before covert we
had trump we had trump we had racism yes
uh we had you know all that so we had
russia collusion of course
and as you referred to in your opening
monologue actually there has been
russian collusion in recent years and
it's one that nobody bothered to talk
about particularly not on the left which
was russia funding all these green
movements and others to persuade
countries like my country of birth not
to frack in fact this week as boris
johnson is going around the middle east
persuading all these charming regimes to
pump more oil
they are filling in the two sites in the
uk which they explored for fracking and
filling them with cement it's like none
of it makes sense it only happened
because the russians helped to terrify
us through the green lobby that fracking
was this incredibly dangerous thing that
would cause earthquakes and tsunamis
rather than as most of the time a rumble
that's no bigger than an average freight
lorry it is amazing because you think
about tyrus like for the like the past
10 years all the stuff all the
documentaries all the hollywood
celebrities all the stuff about fracking
might have all been driven by russia or
at least paying for that because when
they get this script they never ask who
wrote it
right it sounds good i mean the
uncomfortable truth and
then the latest thing where a nuclear
war is going to be bad for the climate
you think
[Laughter]
it's not does it's designed to wipe out
all life scorched earth the good news is
for the woke is that once the giant
cloud of death fills over the sky the
earth will cool two degrees
so it will be a little bit cooler in the
ash filled
world we're walking around in with no
water you can drink a food but we will
be cooler yes so yes they're right it
will be bad for the environment
and everyone within seven miles of it at
first and then everyone within 400 miles
of it because radiation tends to grow so
it's just yeah they got it right they
just
not even close on getting it right i
just hope that like
if there is a catastrophic climate
change and nuclear war that they cancel
each other out
right so they're both getting unfollowed
by me on twitter 100
you know what that's gonna happen i'm
going to make climate change my avatar
just as a just show that i'm involved
i'm in it with you thank you so much
hashtag we don't like i'll be the tree
and you'll get a little squirrel
oh you know how i like the nuts okay
well i did it to myself
[Laughter]
you walked you were supposed to walked
in your eyes wide shut
kat um did you uh i want you to talk a
little bit about uh this uh kind of
secret agenda that russia did with the
environment reverse what did did you
watch zilinski did you catch it at all
this morning yeah i watched some of it
for sure did it move the needle and you
know what needle i'm talking about oh
not the ones not the ones i inject
myself with when i'm doing drugs on the
street all day except for when i'm
sitting right here
i get them confused because i'm glad you
said that i do do so many intravenous
drugs do not put words in my mouth but
you weren't thinking what i was thinking
uh no i mean look i think that you know
he presented a great case but again it
is so important that we don't start
world war three
uh and i think i agree with buck that
it's so great that people do understand
what no-fly zone means now because a lot
of the polling revealed that saying
every people all these people were for a
no-fly zone but they say oh that
actually involves us having to like
shoot down russians they're like oh i
don't want that well that's what that is
so i think it's
really important obviously to make sure
that we don't get involved
in something like that especially it's
like we ended afghanistan or that's over
so now we just send all this troops
somewhere else it's pretty awful it is
weird there's like this spectrum okay on
on let's say one to 10 to spectrum here
on this side you have
iraq and on this side you have world war
ii and you're watching the kind of the
that your your your mo your heart says
this is like world war ii
but your mind says
um what if it's iraq like you know we
went into iraq talking about democracy
and we
that's that's what everyone's wanted by
everyone's wanted by the fact that
america hasn't won a war in quarter of a
century yeah and that we worry you know
what if we go in again yeah um but i
mean i agree with what cat just said by
the way i mean did you see this there
was a great uh thing that happened at
the guggenheim which is where i always
look to for foreign policy
a collective of artists took over the
guggenheim the other day and through
paper airplanes i saw that because they
said they were for a no-fly zone yeah
and the great thing about this is that
these if they get their way and then
world war three starts i reckon those
same artists will be saying stop them
not the war
the more we started you have to
understand they thought safe space
was like no-fly zone
that was the confusion they just thought
they just drew a little line or when the
librarian says you're in a no-talking
zone yes it's not like you just get to
wave your hand in the russian plane but
in this one you get a mushroom cloud
yeah it's so it's so interesting to
think that maybe people didn't
understand that they thought no fly zone
was like an agreement that you make
tick-tock hasn't explained it yet we've
got to wait
we need it we need an influencer i need
a teenager to tell me what's going on
yes who doesn't
me me me too hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else